thank you
foreign
[Music]
yo
oh y'all see how that music changed when
we pulled up on a shouty
[Music]
one sec boom
we in there
what's goody fam
holy comedy
we are back
it's good to see all y'all in here I see
Tommy
La Joy already commenting in the
building was Poppin fam
look at Tommy popping in there
appreciate that the first comment of the
day good to see you buddy as we say here
angels
what's goody what is goody hot breath
verse
Welcome to our weekly q a
Yoshi will be joining us shortly
she was dropping his kids off
as um
Yoshi has a family and real world
responsibilities
and he still joins us every Tuesday
so
be sure to show him a lot of gratitude
when he gets in here
for all that
extra
sacrifice he makes to make these happen
Aaron Arledge good to see you there
Aaron
we posted in our Facebook group
Gathering questions for today so if you
haven't
posted on that post yet do go to our
Facebook group and
Post in there
postender
[Music]
whoa
your boy just got back from a run of
shows
in North Carolina and Virginia I was
gone all of half the week last week
we'll get into it though
[Music]
all right
looks like we have our special guest you
ready Yoshi
can you hear me can you hear me can you
hear me can you feel me can you feel me
can you feel me
yeah you out here I'm I'm out here can
you hear me can you hear me can you hear
me can you hear me can you hear me can
me yes sir can you hear me now can you
can you can you can you hear me now can
you hear me
you can hear me yes sir oh yeah
yeah yeah
we in here
[Music]
what's that oh I thought I heard a
humming is your phone going off
no
no you hear a humming
it sounds like one of those it sounds
like the like feedback you would get if
like a phone was near
you know what I mean how it has that
little like buzzing sound
it may be gone now though
okay
yeah right now
okay Bet
oh Dan Conroy in here keto Carol made it
to the World Series of Comedy Phoenix
satellite
nice keto very nice
Let's uh
there we go
[Applause]
a little sound effect going on there
so we're starting a little bit late
today
um because this is free
[Laughter]
uh so you're welcome
hahaha
hilarious
yep Yoshi um you know Yoshi is
picking up his kids right before this
you're picking up some and dropping some
off literally right before this every
day yeah and I just spent over an hour
editing a single crowd work clip so
going pretty good over here hey we are
setting the bar for greatness you know
yes yes if you're not about this life
then you you ain't ready to for the get
down you know what I mean big fat
big facts
so we
are doing our live q a today
yeah do you need to say anything before
we start Yoshi I'm gonna play the theme
song and then the the show will begin
uh no let's get him super excited to
answer questions to be of service to the
comedy community let's go baby
yes this is our weekly q a live stream
we do every Tuesday on our YouTube
channel in our Facebook group we post
a post for you to ask your questions and
then we answer them live on the air so
if you're listening to the podcast right
now go subscribe to our YouTube channel
go join our Facebook group and become a
part of the conversation
yeah see y'all there
yeah hot breath hot breath
but as we get into the Q and A's here
you like that a little halitosis
[Laughter]
I uh I got to meet some hot breathers
this past week I went I was on the road
for like four days Wednesday to Sunday
it's five days four days I was on the
road for a minute got to see some hot
breather so shout out to boys all the
hot breathers that I got to see in North
Carolina and Virginia
is it brothers or brethrens and cisterns
I I go back and forth I don't know it
depends on how many words I want to say
so
I
if I feel like saying more words I'll
say hot Brethren and sister and then if
I'm just feeling word economy I just go
hot breathers and they get it for sure
[Laughter]
it's hot bees we just I saw some hot
bees out some might be yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and there's a there's a comedian in the
Philippines that had messaged me with
some asking for some advice for
this contest he was doing and then he
messaged me back and said it went really
well and all that so
I love it a meal
Buena Ventura
so nice I love getting those messages
from around the world man so do reach
out to us on social media let us know
absolutely about your comedy Journey
feel free to ask any questions
you did five days in like a couple of
cities or just one
yeah I was in Mooresville North Carolina
and then I was in Lynchburg Virginia and
then I was in Richmond for two days nice
awesome dude so got to
um got to see my old college roommate
on a Saturday night he came out to the
show got to go meet his family and then
went he came to the show
in Richmond Saturday night the late
Saturday show which was of course
the drunk show it was like babysitting I
mean it went it
all the shows went great and I I'm great
I actually filmed all of them I'm
getting in the content game we're
playing it Yoshi yup it's we're doing it
all right we're doing filmed every
single set I had a live mic on nice
we're going for it it's been over an
hour editing one crowd work clip this is
very sustainable yeah
completely One Clip
now we gotta get to the rest of 45
minutes the other 45 minutes so it's
another 45 hours and we'll get to that
by Tuesday by next Tuesday we will have
45 hours
but it's sick yeah it's about cereals
you know how I'm with cereal so
people go check that out on my Instagram
and my Facebook page
but yeah they were all great they were
all great uh it was good to get back on
the road and be headlining and really
feel that extra time and really have fun
with it so it was it was all positive
man it was it just feels good to get
back out there
nice that's awesome that's very awesome
yeah so and shout out to uh David
Goolsby who opened up for me for like
three of those four nights he had um on
that Saturday late show he had one of my
favorite lines
where he did uh he did his merch pitch
for his stickers and he goes all right
I'm gonna do one more joke and then
never do comedy again
such a great that's such a great line
that's like a really good like inside
baseball comedian joke did the crowd
enjoy that
yeah they kind of giggled at it yeah
okay that's funny that's right yeah they
were yeah they were just kind of drunk
so it was like one of those that like
you just get what you can from them you
don't you don't because you know we
always want laughs to be a 10. but some
audiences are literally like a six and
they have a great time yeah as a
collective they're like you know
something it's like they have like
what's that word like uh intuition with
each other it's like hey guys uh We're
not gonna be a 10 audience together
we're gonna be a six and that's how
we're gonna stay okay yep they don't say
it but you could just feel it yeah and I
think that's it's I think it's something
young Comics will do is in those shows
they'll get mad at the audience or
they'll take it out on the audience or
be like what's wrong with y'all like why
aren't y'all laughing more or whatever
instead of having that Awareness on
stage of like okay so this is what this
audience is and let's just still give
them a great show still perform as if it
is a 10 and whatnot because a lot of
times those shows
first off people don't come to a comedy
show to not be at a comedy show so don't
get mad at them for being there first
off
and not being what you want them to be
but second off a lot of times those
shows that's what people come up to you
afterwards and be like oh my gosh you
were hilarious thank you so much I
needed to laugh like just because
they're not laughing at a 10 every time
doesn't mean they're not having a good
time doesn't mean that you're bombing
doesn't mean you get angry at them but
part of the job of a comedian is you
perform in every in any situation and
you're professional that's when you're a
professional Community when you can
perform regardless of the circumstance
and give the same show to 10 people that
you would to 10 000 people
absolutely yeah that's uh that's a good
tip just not to berate the audience uh
or attack the audience or just like put
an audience in an awkward spot to where
they now feel pressured to try to do
something different than what they were
doing before when you talk to an
audience like that or you say you know
something you guys just aren't that
great
you are literally set a stage for
yourself where they don't know whether
to laugh at you more or whether they
should be cautious about everything
you're going to say because you've sort
of broken the wall of just like Hey
we're out here to have a good time it's
okay that they don't laugh at your joke
like to your point like maybe they're
just a six as an audience together and
that's as high as they're gonna go every
comedian will tell you I've seen
comedians who have killed an eight
o'clock show where it was like raucous
10 o'clock show comes around
and it's at a five
and there's nothing or anything that
they said that was any different than
the eight o'clock show yeah
yeah I mean it's just to your point an
audience is just gonna be an audience
but yeah don't don't berate your
audience they're they're still there to
have a good time
yeah and I do want to confirmed David
did not like berate the audience or
anything he had that funny line at the
end of his [__] throughout his set he
just he kept going he kept chopping I
love it I gave him respect for that oh
yeah I love that I mean I just think
like that's just but I think it's also
okay to like
it's okay to like say something about
their energy as long as like you turn it
into a positive you know what I'm saying
like something where it's more about you
than it is about them like I've I've
heard an audience be I've heard
comedians be like you know something you
guys as an audience are really great but
I wouldn't invite you to my wedding you
know what I mean yeah yeah yeah which I
think is funny right you still make it a
little bit personal and yeah you just
kind of dug at them before but that's
still something they could laugh at
versus being like man you guys are
terrible kind of thing so you just gotta
there's a fine line in like berating or
like roasting an audience I think to
your point that you never want to roast
them because their energy will shift as
soon as you start going in a little too
much
yeah especially when you're
inexperienced like it's like we saw we
saw Joe lauers who we've had on the
podcast CEO of World Series of Comedy we
saw him here in Atlanta like that last
show was the audience wasn't great and
he let them know it but this is a guy
who's been doing comedy over 20 years
who understands how to read an audience
how to interact with an audience in a
playful way
that is I mean he did berate them and he
did like roast them but they loved it
and it's they loved it that's a
professional like it takes years to be
able to like have oh my God rapport with
an audience
that kind of audience before because my
favorite line that Joe did mention he
was like uh I'd like you guys to all get
each other's numbers and uh the next
time you want to go out make sure you
call those people and make sure you
don't go out together because yeah
you're not great individually you're
probably awesome but as a collective
I just wouldn't hang out again together
I was like that's just funny right but
it's just to your point like you gotta
have experience to be able to like
get that kind of ribbing in an audience
and then they're still they're laughing
at him and laughing at themselves all at
the same time which I think is like that
fine point
yeah yeah so nice little opening tip
there for all the the comics out there
if a show isn't going how you
thought it would go you just gotta keep
going fam you gotta they can't all be
winners yep they can't all be winners
but you still gotta go
dude I was literally just heard Mark
Norman talking about one of his late
shows like last weekend I think it was
the Saturday late show and he's talking
about how drunk it was and how out of
control it was and he was in a theater
like this is a guy with a big fan base
and even he at his level still has to
struggle with these things so just know
even as a young comic or wherever you
are in the game like these shows happen
these experiences happen and how you
handle them as a professional
is really kind of the difference between
an amateur and a comedian people want to
pay to see
facts
but yeah it was all it was all gravy it
was all all good fam look at you
dropping boys
Joe boar Joel bars
they call me Joe Joe Bowers
hmm
Joel bars
all right
so we can get into the questions here we
go
put the timer up
um
um when we did the rapid fire
up let's see let's see how we can go
because people are liking these I've
been getting messages about how people
are liking these and um
last week like each
week on the podcast I'll look at like
the first 24 hours of like how many
listens we're getting and each each week
has been getting more and more in like
24 hours so
thank you guys we appreciate y'all yeah
so
uh the first question I'm seeing here
um
is Jack Allen
our hot Brethren from across the pond he
asks what is your best tip for handling
a heckler
okay so I think uh
you know hecklers are one of those
things because heck coolers come in all
different shapes and sizes right they're
kind of just like not all hecklers are
built the same way
I think it's important to at least
acknowledge a Heckler in terms of at
least call out what is happening
but when you do call out a Heckler I
think it's also important to make sure
that you're not demeaning a Heckler like
if the Heckler says something like a
word or something like that it's always
good to like just repeat what that
Heckler said
and then sort of try to turn whatever
they said back into a joke
if the Heckler is being uh what's the
word if they're just saying things
they're kind of being disruptive but
they're not being demonstrative towards
the you or towards like the show
because every once in a while I think I
understand that like some people might
just feel moved just to say something
during a show like it just might be like
like out here during the show like good
God that's hilarious or like just during
a silence or even like someone reacts to
something or they're like they might be
thinking of like a tag oh yeah that's
what she said right even those kinds of
things are completely okay I wouldn't I
would say even in those situations I'd
never bereate a Heckler only time you
really want to berate a Heckler is that
if they are completely disturbing the
show
and in those situations
I would just be like hey uh security can
you guys just handle this person
try to do the back and forth with
hecklers I feel like crowd work Clips
are making it seem as if though peop
everyone can handle a Heckler and that's
not the case those hecklers that show up
on crowd Clips are from videos that have
been edited
most of those situations do not go that
well
situations don't go that well this is
from like people doing so much crowd
work all right we found that one out of
the 50 crowd work clips that I did we
found the one that I'm gonna put up
makes it seem as if though this is what
happens every time at my show so uh in
conclusion I would say do whatever you
can not to berate a Heckler turn
whatever they say into a positive and if
it gets demonstrative just ask the uh
venue if there's security hopefully to
just take care of it that's how I
approach heckwords is no matter what I
always try to spin it into a positive
yeah it's important to be able to
identify the type of heckle it is like
if is it someone trying to disturb the
show or is it someone that's just
excited and just yelling something or
someone who's just drunk and doesn't
maybe even realize what they're doing
but I think an important thing to
understand with a Heckler is that
the audience is on your side so always
they're they're rooting for you they're
the Heckler is annoying them as much as
is annoying you so you don't you don't
have to address you don't have to fight
fire with fire and if like they're
yelling at you you don't have to like
yell back at them but like the more
almost
the more almost like reason you can
address a Heckler with the Dumber
they're gonna look and the more the
audience will be on your side to really
be like yeah just yeah stop or whatnot
but it all starts with like
recognizing what type of Heckler it is
to then be able to address it in the
best way possible
but I will say
that it requires
I I hate it come I don't hate it comes
back to that that's the reality but it
requires a lot of stage time and it
requires you getting heckled a lot and
it requires you not handling a Heckler
the right way to then learn how to
handle the heck with the right way like
it really does but being able to
identify the Heckler and then
understanding that the audience is on
your side and even getting the audience
involved with the situation of like if
they're yelling at you could be like why
are you yelling none of us does anyone
else want this person to keep yelling or
whatnot like get the audience involved
in handling this Heckler that takes the
pressure off you as well of trying to
figure out something clever or whatnot
but no one in the audience is excited
there's a Heckler so the more you can
get the audience involved in quote
handling this Heckler I think the easier
it'll be for you and the quicker it'll
get extinguished as well yeah I've seen
a comedian do this trick which I thought
was pretty solid uh uh which was they
acknowledge they're like a Heckler said
something and then they just repeated
what they said said man that's hilarious
and then they literally moved on to the
next joke like and that was it like they
just acknowledged it oh that's funny
moved on to the next joke
and then like the Heckler just stopped
and I think sometimes hecklers are
believing that they want attention and
if you don't give them that attention
they might just stop not all heckwords
to your point not all hecklers are the
same but I think sometimes hecklers
sometimes people believe that they are
enhancing your show because they don't
know the sort of
uh comedy mores I think that's a liberal
arts word like they don't know the
comedy rules you know what I'm saying
like or like
they don't know what to how to act at a
comedy show so they're like trying to
figure out well based on the clips that
I've seen you just talk during the
comedian set and then they'll interact
with you it's like that's not how Comedy
Works but they don't know they just
think that's what they see on shows
mores
yeah what does that mean
it's how do you spell decorum
oh Decor oh you
Marines like decorum
yeah
I was trying to I was trying to uh but
yeah m-o-r-e-s
m-o-r-e-s yeah oh
that is a really good point uh oh yeah
Murray's let's see
mores the accepted traditional customs
and usages of a particular social group
yes that's good that's really good
that's a really good point Bravo
[Laughter]
but yeah that is a that's a good point
of like repeating what the Heckler says
as well because a lot of times same
thing with crowd work you want to like
repeat what the person you're doing
crowd work with says because most of the
audience probably can't hear them so
repeating him gets everyone on the same
page as well to keep going instead of
like I see a lot of people doing crowd
work where they're just having a
conversation with the person and half
the audience has no idea even like
what's going on and the same can be true
with handling a Heckler as well so
that's a really good point
yeah
nice very nice
yeah great question because I know
that's um that's a that's a Hot Topic
that is a Hot Topic but just approach a
Heckler conversationally don't try to
fight fire with fire
yeah and I just know the audience is on
your side and ignoring them is very
powerful like you usually what I'll do
with a Heckler is I'll let him yell a
few times
and if they I mean like if they still I
just ignore them because it can derail
the show and they think they're a part
of it and a lot of times you do ignore
them they will actually stop
and if they don't stop I'll literally
like shush them
just very like politely I'll just be
like shh like at them I'll just shush
them and then go right back to the show
like I don't even address that I just
shush this person like I just keep going
and that'll a lot of times get on be
like oh maybe I should shush and if they
keep going then I'll like address them
but I do I give them a few strikes
before I just you know go and like all
right now the show is over here like
you'll be surprised you just keep going
and they'll usually stop too
for sure I will say I've seen shushing
done
um I think shushing is one of those
things that has a bit of power
if you are an intimidating person
you're tall so people very few times
will try to shush back because it's
there's a very like significant like
power play at shushing I've seen women
try to shush guys and guys got like
super upset like did not like being
shushed
you know what I'm saying even though
they deserve it
you know what I'm saying so there's a
privilege element of like but I think
it's important to still use it like it's
good to still try it you're like hey
would you mind and then get back to your
show you what I'm saying but yeah I
think it's a powerful tool of uh maybe
just like not acknowledging but I think
it's it's just only if it feels like
everyone feels it if everyone feels that
this person is literally disturbing the
show I think you gotta address it in
some way
nice
and that comes with experience for sure
yes
so I think we have addressed addressing
a we have addressed addressing hecklers
I think we've got that one
um next question
in our Facebook group
Aaron Arledge
should you go to open mics that make you
pay or buy stuff I always try to buy
something when I do open mics but making
it mandatory
doesn't sit well with me
um
you know I I
I would say it just depends on how deep
your pockets are and how much stage time
you really need
uh I don't have like a blanket rule like
if you're okay because really all
they're really doing is just trying to
find a way to support the venue that's
really what that is is that the venue is
just trying to make sure that whoever
comes in that they're getting something
out of it so it's mostly just to keep
the lights on with most places that do
that I don't think necessarily that
there's I don't think that the uh
a comedian or most comedians are getting
a kickback from you buying food or you
buying drinks at most venues very few
venues I know give comedians oh we're
going to give you part of the sales of
the beer that you sell that are sold
during the time that you did the open
mic
yeah you need to do that you know what
I'm saying yeah uh I think it's a matter
of whether you want to support that
venue or not and if you don't and if
that doesn't sit well with you I'm
always about energy that doesn't sit
well with you skip that open mic try to
go to something else like if that just
doesn't feel right but just I I would
just play Devil's Advocate to let you
know that that's not something that
necessarily
was asked for that's probably just a
condition for someone to actually do the
open mic there it's not like uh
something that was like oh yeah I'm also
going to charge any comedian that comes
in you know just to make sure I get
they're not getting most Comics aren't
getting any money from any venue selling
beer or selling food
yeah that's um
try to think of a
trying to think of the shows I mean I've
I've only paid to be on like a handful
of shows I think in New York I paid to
be on a show
and I literally
went up last and I literally every comic
went up this was in the basement of a
bar every comic went up and then
immediately left so by the end of the
show it was literally me and the host
I sat through this entire Open Mic got
paid to be a part of probably 20 comics
on it and I went up last me and
literally me and the host left in the
basement of this bar and that was it
was it a good set though
[Laughter]
to another show so that was cool so for
sure
uh you had to pay 16 for this drink uh I
might as well show you something else
yeah I think yeah I think I paid ten
um for that stage time so I've only done
a handful of times but yeah if it
doesn't well with you then yeah just
don't do it and if you don't mind and
can do it then yeah do it kind of
personal preference there but yeah no
one's yeah no comic is getting rich off
that scheme I can't imagine
at least the vast majority I can't
imagine that someone's hosting a show to
get money from Comics you know that's
probably the venue yes
a good question there yeah that's a good
question
um
Jeff ardle
is there any value in hot breath
sponsoring open mics and the pros in the
group doing shows
at the satellite shows
sadly is he talking about the World
Series
or is he talking about something else
um
I don't know
is there a value of hot press sponsoring
open mics and the pros in the group
doing shows that the satellite shows
um
I mean I don't I get there is value in
hot breath sponsoring open mics I would
say
at some point yeah I don't hate it I
mean we're definitely going to be we're
definitely going to do more Live Events
and stuff
yeah yeah
um that's definitely part of the plan
yep
um and things like that so yeah we'll
definitely be doing more of that we're
just we're
eating this elephant one bite at a time
yeah yeah yeah that's a good way of
putting it yeah so there's definitely
value in it for sure
um I think we're just trying to find a
way we're looking for ways to sort of
scale it and get into sort of something
that's like a regular rotation so if we
do like go out if you and I go out to
like a city we could probably do a show
right and then get hot Brethren's to and
sister students to come out and do the
show with us but yeah definitely yeah
we've I feel like we talked about that
like
day two when we got together on hot
bread we were just like yeah that's a
great idea that's that's definitely sort
of the vision of it of yes we want to
try to find more ways to get comedians
more stage time and to also help
comedians out so
sort of having an open mic with hot
breath folks is yeah that's a plus that
sounds amazing
yeah so anyone listening to this and you
know of a show in your area that you
think Yoshi and I would be good for hit
us up I mean we're you know
holla at the kids yeah we we game to do
shows for the hot breadth of Earth we
love
we love meeting you all and doing shows
together and we want to do more of that
so definitely reach out to us
slide in the DMs
[Laughter]
slide to the left
oh wait where'd it go
there we go oh
um
Clyde Williams
is there any particular strategy adding
callbacks to your set
strategy
I don't know if a strategy
yeah I think it's a good idea to add
callbacks I think callbacks work I would
say and I remember when we were doing
um
the type 5 accelerator uh for a couple
of them
um one of the Maybe
the Jason Roland from a World Series the
vice president of the World Series was
mentioning how
he's not crazy about callbacks for a
five minute set
like it's not necessarily for a five
minute set because it's five minutes of
just you proving that you can do jokes
whereas a callback maybe you know is
probably good if you're doing like 10 15
maybe even 20 minutes because you get to
established yourself but if you're
trying to squeeze a call back in within
five minutes I remember him mentioning
that that's not a great idea because
it's not needed because it feels like
you're just trying to force the Callback
versus just showcasing your best
material so if now if the Callback is
literally your best stuff then sure do
it but if it's not your best stuff then
don't do that in a showcase set of five
minutes
so I don't know if that answers a
question or not uh from a strategy
perspective I I do like the philosophy
if you're doing like
15 minutes for sure I had a call back I
think
an audience would appreciate it because
callbacks make an audience feel super
smart like they were in on the joke
itself yeah for sure when it works it
works really really well when it doesn't
or Falls flat it does fall flat so I
would just say play with it and see what
happens but I don't think callbacks are
needed for short sets but definitely for
longer sets I think they're a good
strategy
yeah and it I think the yeah the only
strategy would be to just make it
organic you know I mean I personally
don't mind a call back in a five minute
set like if it's organic and if it fits
and it doesn't feel forced so yeah just
make sure whatever callback you do have
that it's
it's organic and it makes sense
and it's like a part of the set and not
like something you just tried to like
squeeze in there yeah
yeah great point
yeah and if people I mean a callback is
basically a reference to something you
said earlier in the Set uh if people are
singing maybe don't know what a callback
is so if you mention like your dog
your dog's name and then later in your
set you mention the dog's name again
it's like you could be talking about
walking your dog and then maybe at the
grocery store and someone barks at you
or another dog barks at you and you're
like oh you're not Fido that was a
terrible example
um
that was a horrendous example yeah
that's why you should work on callbacks
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
try and even think
of I can't even think of one that I do
oh really I'm trying to think of one for
you I have a call back about a joke that
I make around bathroom humor stuff
uh
but I do it mostly in like
I'll do a call back in a 45
35 25 minutes that that's usually when
like something past 20 minutes I'll do
callbacks mostly because I like
the audience like sense of oh my God he
called that back like I love ending on a
Big callback with a big joke
so my closers typically have callbacks
to something else that I've said in the
set to end the show because then people
feel like oh my God that's a good button
you know I mean like I think it's just
like the storytelling thing right it's
like any good movie that has a Good
callback to it you're always like oh
that was pretty solid so yeah closer is
a good way to yeah callbacks are good
for closers yeah yeah
okay cool yeah good question though yeah
work on the callbacks don't don't be
like Joel don't just make him up on the
spot just yeah that was bad I mean no
the one that comes to mind is I have a
joke about football and concussions
being getting your bell rung and then I
do an act out
of me getting a concussion and I use
like the phrase getting your bell rung
so
so that it's like a chunk it's like a
bit about concussions now being used to
be called getting your bell rung and
then I do an act out and use the phrase
getting your bell rung so it calls it
back that way but yeah it's usually
callbacks are usually good for closers
like a nice little button on the set
nice little button little button mores
[Laughter]
um
Phil ketron
asked I struggle with what is clean as I
use a lot of sexual innuendos any
suggestions
um
I think it's funny because we're both
pretty clean comedians I probably do
more cursing than you do on shows but
for the most part we're both pretty
clean probably and I have jokes where I
do sexual innuendos and uh I actually
just did a joke with yes I did a joke I
just did a show with uh Andrew Stanley
who's absolutely hilarious one of the
best comedians I think in the city super
hilarious and he's got some jokes that
are sexual innuendo and he's a clean
comedian and so if you ever want to like
watch someone does really good sexual
innuendo stuff uh he's got some good
jokes there I would say the key is to
maybe just
if it feels like people can visually
graph if you just say yeah me and my
wife have sex every once in a while
that's a clean joke there's nothing
wrong with that
but if you're like
start talking about penetration and butt
stuff you're like oh dude like just I
just said those two things and already
Joel just felt awkward about it I bowed
my head in prayer I'm gonna yeah pray
for you those are clean words that I
just said but yet it made him feel a
certain type of way that to an audience
is not what you want for a clean set
if that makes sense I hope that makes
sense I hope that was a good example of
just like even if you're like I remember
I put a comedian on the show and they
said hey can I say the word anal and
then I was like uh let's skip it and
then oh joke to butt stuff and I was
just like that didn't help the joke be
any cleaner just because you said butt
stuff you know what I'm saying like it
was still a dirty joke because you
didn't change any part of it you just
changed the word but the joke was so
dirty that it didn't matter whether you
just changed the word to where you
didn't say the word anal or not so uh I
think it's about you know you just gotta
think like I always say
if you think clean the best way to think
about clean is something you'd say
around your grandparents that's clean
right yeah unless you have just super
filthy grandparents you know what I'm
saying but just think of like a group of
grandparents getting together
that is the audience you should think
about for your material when it comes to
clean
yeah and clean is
it's so subjective like what's clean to
one person
maybe considered dirty to another
there's like PG-13 clean or like so if
you're ever on a show
and you're not sure if something's clean
or not like ask the person yeah booking
it like that comic did with Yoshi you
know just just ask the comic that booked
you is this clean or not but a lot of
the time
if if you have to ask
then
it's probably yeah it's if if you have
to ask it's probably dirty but there's
ways to do
like you said like I think Bill Engvall
is another example of a comedian who
does a lot of innuendo and stuff but
he's considered like he does Blue Collar
Comedy Tour and all that so it's like
he's considered a clean comic so
there are ways to do dirty topics and
just being more clever and you can
actually make them clean and there's
such
there's such a value in doing at least
being able to do clean comedy I
literally
I talked to like a younger comic when I
was in Austin who who was a fan of the
podcast and came up to me and it felt
really cool but he was asking about
clean comedy
and he said he was offered a church gig
where he had to do 10 minutes clean for
500 and he turned it down
because he couldn't do clean
that's and he's like a smart move
to and such good awareness to not take
that gig
yeah just to not take the money and ruin
everyone's night yeah most comedians
would just take their set take out the
curse words and be like we're gonna take
this 500. you know what I'm saying yeah
uh but yeah that's such good awareness
to like be like you know something I'm
just not going to be able to do that but
yeah but there's just a value in being
able to be clean and you can usually
turn something dirty clean just by using
different words like whatever the dirty
words are brainstorm different ways you
can say the same thing but without it
being so just graphic or on the nose
[Laughter]
easy ways you can do it like yeah but it
just takes a little more um creativity
and a little extra leg work but it's
worth it
for sure and then you just got to think
even like
if you're doing Church shows right
stay away from sex stay away from
politics stay away from race if possible
right those are the three things that I
would say are like
at church shows just don't work very
well for a clean set
now if you want to talk about traffic
you want to talk about parents that's a
that's like stuff that church material
is like that kills in church material
yeah you know what I mean so I think you
just know
it's just a topic if you're a joke if
your joke is written out uh
uh like is titled sex stuff or has
anything to do with sex that's not the
no matter what you're gonna do not no
matter but like just know maybe you
should revamp that joke to make it a
clean
clean material yeah and speaking of
which if anyone listening to this
is a member of a church
um
holla at your boys we're very capable
and able to perform at church as I
performed at several churches and
corporate events colleges and family
reunions and all sorts of stuff so
we are available for booking and our
wives appreciate it
we should just turn that that should be
the name of the podcast we are available
for booking and our guys appreciate it
yes yeah
all very true
all right next uh next question here oh
this is an interesting one
from Tommy lajoy who also had our first
comment of the day he just said yo but
uh we appreciate that engagement there
Tommy on our YouTube channel he said
do you now use chat GPT to find links
and ideas and do you consider it
cheating to use a chat bot to help you
write
um I have uh recently started using chat
gbt to come up with like fun jokes
um so I did a show out in a city that I
normally host in and I actually used it
as part of my set and I asked the chat
thing to come up with like 10 jokes
about the city and then I read off the
jokes in my set and it was just funny
because
uh the whole point of it was that chat
GPT like doesn't really know anything
about your city it just assumes a whole
bunch of stuff so just know that like
that's the other thing about chat gbt
that people should realize just because
it spits out an answer doesn't actually
mean it's the right answer
like it's not always correct right so
even if you're like because I I uh I was
writing something about like hey give me
Comics who are from Atlanta and I
started naming all these Comics just
normal comics and not like
two of them were from Atlanta but like
eight of them were not I was like oh
it's just going through a database and
just but I think it only spit out Comics
who were super popular and have had
Atlanta shows so you just gotta
understand like there's a difference in
how you ask the chat like for certain
things and it may not know the
difference so yeah I don't think there's
anything wrong with it just know that
like
it's about material if it's helping you
enhance your material for sure uh I
don't see any issues with it it's just
like you know people aware that chat gbt
is going to take over people that write
content it's not
you know people have been writing
content since the dawn of time and
people have gotten help with content
since the double time so I don't see it
being an issue if you use it for
material yeah I I don't see it as
cheating I think it's another tool just
like the one we talked about last week
that you shared in uh the Facebook group
actually that hot brother and imbray
uh created that's like it's like a mind
map one there's like a there's a few
different tools that he he's like he's a
programmer he's he knows code he like
coded these writing tools that um you
guys can see in our Facebook group uh
yeah so I don't if if you use it and it
works for you more power to you it's
just another tool at your disposal I
feel like just like using a thesaurus
you know or any other word hippo is
another like website you know so
I've played around with it a little bit
I haven't gotten anything
like specific from it
but there's a learning curve with
interacting with any Ai and like writing
the correct prompts and knowing what to
ask it and how to ask it to really get
what you want so it's a whole learning
curve there but
yeah more power too if you if you figure
it out and it helps you write material
faster and it works on stage go for it
yeah
yeah like I've seen it I've also asked
it to write like monologue jokes about
like certain news
and it's actually a good starting point
it's shitty with punch lines but it's a
good starting point with like the setup
for sure
because it just doesn't understand like
the human element of the surprise right
so I think that's just yeah find out
what's good in it use that and if it's
not great don't use it
no and at the end of the day it's all
about testing your material on stage it
might sound great coming from chat GPT
but chat GPT cannot guarantee that
people are gonna laugh at you
so we are in um
we got our countdown timer now we're in
The Hot Zone what should we call this
part of the show the hot
Zone the rapid fire the hot round
uh the breath round yeah the breath
round yeah you got to do it within one
breath
all right the breath round we're taking
a deep breath here
um well that's a working title we'll uh
we'll ask chat GPT what's a better title
for this segment
um Oz Morris asked how is the writing
process different between writing jokes
that are open mic funny show funny and
comedy special funny I write daily jokes
but how can you tell this is
comedy special funny or is this Open Mic
or Twitter funny
I mean it's you've got to do it on stage
first to know if it's funny or not
basically
yeah and Twitter this would be funny to
where people read it and they get it
versus if you perform it and they get it
right like if you've got word play stuff
uh wordplay works very well on Twitter
because people can actually see the word
and see what you did with it
um so I think there's a difference there
but I think yeah it's all about like you
know a specials are just super tight
jokes that you've worked on that most
comedians or who are doing like specials
every year they have worked that out
like
almost close to 100 times before they've
ever set it in the special they've seen
that joke work and they've tightened it
up
Open Mic an intro to a joke right like
you're just getting your legs underneath
you and then showcase is just like a
much more solid Open Mic joke you know
what I mean so I think that's really the
key is the stage will tell you when it's
ready for
the big stage you know what I mean when
it's like oh okay now we take it up a
notch
yeah I think I think it starts with you
trying it on stage and that'll help
steer whether or not oh this is maybe a
better tweet or maybe this idea is a
sketch instead of a stand-up bit but
yeah I think it all starts with trying
it out in an open mic and then what what
is kept with a comedy special I mean
gosh my special was 10 years of material
condensed into one special you know so
that's really
that's most people's first special I
think I heard Bert Kreischer say that
your first special takes you 10 years
the next one takes you five and then
from there you can you kind of start to
roll them out quicker now of course
there's I'm sure people listening that
are prodigies that are like but that's
not me and you know you do you boo like
literally it is the wild west out there
if you can build a following online
go for it a hundred percent
um but
um
but yeah that's usually the rule of
thumb so it yeah I would say as it
starts with open mics and that'll help
you to determine where what or if you
want to do anything with that joke
moving forward
for sure
oh and DJ sketch said Spitfire around oh
I like that I do like that I like that
Spitfire
Spitfire around
we'll have to use that sound effect
there oh like yours yours the fire fire
fire
oh yeah yeah let's do it
um
oh oh wait here it is
fire fire fire
all right
I need a countdown timer for that do you
need do you remember Street Fighter did
you ever play Street Fighter mm-hmm
okay there's this there's a character in
Street Fighter that says that fire
fighter fighter fighter I just remember
are you can
yeah doesn't that harm is
uh really skinny guy with long arms and
Long Legs oh yeah yeah
fire fire yeah oh man all right that's a
rabbit Trail let's get back yeah
Yoga Fire yoga flame
um
oh
and this ties in Oz followed up with he
saw a documentary basically that said
you need to stop writing to please
others and write for yourself how do you
do that and I think it is listening
listening to your own Instinct and your
own intuition and your own sense of
humor about what you genuinely find
funny just because you see a comic in
your scene killing with
you know
um an abortion joke or whatnot or you
see Bill Burr saying something like
aggressive about women that you feel
like oh I need a joke like that to
become Bill Burr but it's like no like
you figure out what's funny to you
and write in that direction don't try to
adapt or
steal ideas from other people just
because it's working for them no like
listen to yourself and that um
that sound effect actually did this
young comedian
young comedian Padawan that's a sound
effect from the online class we have
where I'm just telling people throughout
the class to at any moment you know
listen to your intuition listen to your
Sixth Sense which is your sense of humor
and really follow that instinct and that
feeling and intuition that you have and
let that be your guide and not what some
other comic is doing so
that's basically it yeah
but he he kind of always got a double
dip in there but I thought it was a
relevant and good question
um
all right I think we have like two more
here
um
oh this would be a quick one Antonio
Martinez comedy is uh starting to
Showcase very nice
and
wait starting a showcase or show any
tips
oh he's not starting one he want oh he
wants to start one but he needs advice
on finding a venue
and a PA system man this has been a Hot
Topic I think we posted I think I posted
the video of us talking about this but
to sum up finding a venue
find a venue that's gonna actually
be excited to help you
promote
the show and actually work together to
make this a victory and A good rule of
thumb with that is a venue that's
already doing other Live Events like
karaoke or trivia or music so that a
live entertainment is already a natural
extension of what they already do
yep yeah and a PA system you can find
them on Amazon
uh really it's about just starting with
something small that is fits the stage
most PA systems are loud enough to wear
any venue you've got it's gonna be
sizable for it so don't go big on your
first one
and I guarantee you uh Antonio if you
post in our Facebook group asking good
PA systems for a live show yeah I
guarantee
you will get a whole list of them
T guarantee dude I I saw a post
yesterday
a chameleon or a member of the Facebook
group posted like something that
happened with his co-workers his
co-workers so he was like asking for
good like Zinger lines he can hit like
he can uh say about his co-worker and
there was like almost like a hundred
comments on there so
it's very cool to see uh Comics helping
comics in the community coming together
in any way so yeah Post in uh the
Facebook group I guarantee you'll get
some PA system recommendations there
Antonio
and as we start to land the plane
oh Yoshi could be good at this one keto
Carol asked about
um she's in the world series of Comedy
Phoenix and going first in her round
tips for going first
so uh
I would say probably the biggest thing
for going first is to come with energy
if you are the first comedian as a as we
call it the bullet spot in the comedy
World sure the bullet spot just come
with energy mostly because you want to
reset whatever your host did to make
sure that you are remembered as the
first comedian I think it's also it's
always great to be the first comedian
that comes out because you are going to
set the bar for every other comedian so
my biggest tip would be energy when you
get out on stage uh
you know if it's a showcase show
um don't do this do not ask how the
audience is doing
that's tip number two do not ask how the
audience is doing simply like this is
you know there's different ways of
saying this so like hi my name is Yoshi
excited to be here go into your first
line
like something simple as that don't
spend too much time engaging with the
audience right out of the gate just go
into your jokes it's to showcase the the
host is already and should have already
done that job for you you don't need to
interact with the audience or do
anything like that this is a showcase
you have five minutes or seven minutes
whatever you're in to just hit them with
your joke so focus on that but energy as
the bullet spot is a good way to make
sure that you are remembered and have
fun just have fun with it I think with
contests you can overthink it you can
over emphasize the just even what's at
stake like oh I have to do X Y and Z
just have fun and the audience will have
fun absolutely just know that you having
a good time on stage
the audience will also have a good time
on stage so do not re forget to make
sure that you are having a good time on
stage as much as possible
and
the final question
is oh my heavens
is Kim
Cattrall or Cottrell
I don't want to mispronounce her name
but she's a newer member of the Facebook
group so it's always exciting to see new
members
posting questions she said
I have an opener closer and always try
for smooth transitions for a five minute
set is it good to have a strategy like
this for open mics
um
simple answer no I don't think you need
transition for your Open Mic stuff I
think you can go from one idea to the
next idea as long as you make sure that
at whenever you're done with like your
punch line and your tags there's sort of
a natural silence before you go on to
the next thing I don't think you have to
have a transition into your next
material for an open mic
you certainly don't have to it's a
stylistic choice like I always from the
jump have even like the early open mic
days I was always like mindful of like
all right how can I transition from one
thing to the other and make it seem like
like a seamless conversation and I would
organize my jokes accordingly but yeah
there's yeah it's kind of like a call
back it's like
like we said it with a call back earlier
you know they're great as long as
they're not forced same thing with the
transition you know it's like as long as
it's organic and you make it natural in
it not something you're trying to just
shoehorn in there for the sake of you
think you have to do that it's all
personal stylistic preference there yeah
and I think that's how I took the
question like I took the question is is
this something you have to do do you
have to do a transition for an open mic
and the answer is you don't have to if
you do there's nothing wrong with it but
you don't have to do it and I would say
just in a lot of the open mics that I've
seen and I've seen probably a thousand
open mics
it's not needed for you to still get the
same kind of like laughs and or premises
that you're trying to for for your joke
people understand that as soon as
there's a little bit of Silence that
there's a new thought that you're about
to have you don't have to transition
people from one to the other unless like
you mentioned like you mentioned Joel
there's a natural transition like if you
talk about sugar and then you go into
breakfast cereal because you
obsessed with sugar from Saturday
mornings that's a natural transition to
sort of walk into that topic but if you
talk about it and then you want to talk
about like you know let's say Bluetooth
cameras or something like that you don't
need to try to find a transition between
those two yeah the audience fought the
audience will follow you like if you go
from one topic to the next no one's
gonna be like oh where's the Segway
where's the transition they're they're
just listening to you they'll they'll go
wherever you take them absolutely yeah
yep
nice
yeehaw
we did it we do
we're people that are listening to the
podcast or watching this later we do
this live stream every Tuesday we would
love to meet you we would love to talk
to you so please set a reminder for
every Tuesday at 5 PM Eastern Standard
Time we're on here answering your
questions live
and we want to meet you and do shows
together if you have shows DM us on
social media at hot breath pod
and we're back next Tuesday anything
else Yoshi
no player it was uh fun I had a good
weekend shows got more stuff coming up
super excited uh summer months are gonna
be good man uh yeah just super excited
about what we got going on
you cooking you cooking up some over
there
um um yeah man I'm cooking
[Music]
yeah yeah no no I'm trying I'm trying to
like uh
uh I have a My Mind Set On doing like a
specialist
I figured your date yet but just got a
nice little thought process and trying
to figure out all the pieces of making
it work
um oh we're getting recorded yeah hot
Brothers special uh
sort of uh was like my inspiration like
of just like putting that work in Man of
just like practicing and getting it nice
and tight because I feel like I have
material that I usually always conscious
of is like the timing that your special
had to be like an hour because that's
what everyone does but it's like it
doesn't have to be an hour I'm thinking
about putting like a 44 minute special
up you know I mean just it's 44 minutes
of Miles yeah so just thinking about
like just how to make that happen in the
next couple of months so I'm super
excited about that
well we're here for you buddy so
anything we can do to help with that
that is very exciting
yeah very excited about that
my guy all right well stay tuned hot
breathaverse
more to come on Yoshi's comedy special
so book him book him so he can get those
reps so he doesn't bomb and embarrass
the whole hot breath of Earth
just kidding
he's gonna kill it
very nice all right
we're gonna get out of here
get out
bye bye y'all
we love you happy grinding out there
see y'all next Tuesday
peace
thank you
hot breath